but there is some positive breaking news
this morning another potential
coronavirus vaccine is showing very
promising results
charlie daggett is at oxford university
in england with more on the astrazeneca
vaccine trial
charlie i know the medical community
very excited about this one so what
makes this
different than the other ones that we've
talked about
and good morning they're very excited
here at oxford gail
happening to you and here's why it not
only performed as well as they'd hoped
it would
but this vaccine might stop the
transmission of the virus
too large-scale trials showed the
vaccine prevented more than 70 percent
of people from getting covid
that number jumps up to 90 percent if
half the dose is used followed by a
booster shot of a full dose
data shows it works across all age
groups
and it's safe mild side effects include
headache fatigue
and a sore arm volunteers were also
swabbed on a weekly basis
to see if it showed a reduction in
asymptomatic cases
when people spread the virus without
knowing they had it
the reason we did all of those swabs was
to ask the question could a vaccine
prevent transmission as well as disease
and this is one way of doing that i
think it's the first vaccine to report
on that end point the us warp speed
program
has pumped more than a billion dollars
into the development of the oxford
vaccine
and returned for an initial rollout of
300 million doses
the vaccines only need basic
refrigeration rather than deep freeze
temperatures
that makes distribution easier and
faster
upscaling the manufacture of the vaccine
is also easier
and astrazeneca have pledged to make 3
billion doses
in 2021.
now the big question when are we going
to see it in the united states well
astrazeneca said today they're in
conversations their words with the fda
but it is possible that this vaccine may
be rolled out to other countries
before it reaches america anthony all
right but
a vaccine that prevents transmission
that's really encouraging news charlie
daggett in england thanks charlie